à votre avis il y a des chances pour
comprendre de quoi toi et moi ou
[Rires]
comme vous êtes deux stars on va vous
faire une interview star by star
[Musique]
c'est la marque ça se passe
alors d'abord Michel vous allez vous
asseoir derrière le petit bureau du lait
chaud vous ferez ce soir dans le dans le
fauteuil club et ensuite nous
inverserons les rôles
d'accord est-ce que vous m'admirez oui
merci alors
ça vous fait quoi de jouer avec moi
est-ce que vous avez des vues sur moi
oui merci alors
[Rires]
on vous a déjà dit que vous ressembliez
plus à gérardz ou à Gérard Philipe
oui bon ça va alors
Gérard Philippe
est-ce qu'on vous a déjà appelé Francis
hamster
[Rires]
pourquoi ne vous laissez-vous pas
pousser la moustache je l'ai fait dans
un film edit à Marcel de Claude
lelouchman je me rappelle qu'est-ce que
tu étais bien dans ce film c'est sympa
est-ce que vous avez vu mon spectacle le
démon de midi non mais j'ai tu m'as
envoyé le DVD avant qu'on commence les
répétitions pour que je sache il avait
besoin de se rassurer
ton charme fou
non c'est vrai ton charme fou merci mon
amour alors qu'est-ce que vous aimez le
moins en moi ça cette question est nulle
si vous aviez une chose à changer en moi
ce serait quoi
j'essaierai de te donner plus de
confiance en toi justement
à refaire c'est pas ta refaire mais si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous
changeriez dans cette interview
tout
merci bon maintenant
on change de place et penser sur Terre
va devenir comme dans nuit d'ivresse un
vrai animateur de télévision à vous
Francis
ça vous a fait quoi la première fois
qu'on s'est vu ça m'a fait drôle parce
que comme je suis amoureuse de toi
depuis l'année dernière
ça m'a fait tout drôle je croyais pas
que tu existait en vrai
on va changer des trucs dans la mise en
scène alors
qu'est-ce que vous pensiez de moi avant
la pièce ça on passe à votre avis
qu'est-ce que je pense de vous
du bien qu'est-ce que vous pensez à moi
après la pièce
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu comme chance à
votre avis il y a des chances pour
comprendre
de quoi toi et moi ou
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez vu ma série télé le
grand patron bien sûr
si vous avez gardé vos cheveux est-ce
pour mieux vous démarquer de votre père
le Professeur Choron alors oui et non
mais j'aurais bien aimé être tendu mais
c'est la moustache à moi par contre qui
me va pas du tout est-ce que vous a déjà
dit que vous ressembliez plus au
professeur Tournesol qu'au Professeur
Choron non on m'a déjà dit professeur
Cabrol professeur coron professeur
chaudron professeur mais je ressemble à
mon père effectivement qu'est-ce que
vous aimez le plus chez vous
pas grand chose
qu'est-ce que vous aimez le moins chez
vous
[Rires]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu